it is really cold here today minus 8
degrees in the eastern city of kharkiv
the losses are so great that reports are
rendered in numbers
400 buildings destroyed since the war
began
including 48 schools 190 civilians dead
residential areas struck 89 times in a
single day
as if counting them somehow completes
the picture as one bombed out building
starts to look much like another
they don't wait for air raid sirens
anymore in kharkiv many haven't left the
city's metro stations for more than a
week
here is where i sleep this young woman
says
and over there are my things and there
is where we all sit
ever more civilians are getting caught
up in this war ukraine's defense
minister says russia has killed more
innocent people than it has ukrainian
soldiers one day war historians may
argue about which city had it worst
today though it is surely mario pole
that is most like ukraine's stalingrad
besieged for more than ten days hundreds
of thousands unable to escape deprived
of water and heat in temperatures well
below zero a red cross official in the
city describes children going hungry a
black market in vegetables fights
breaking out over food conditions the
mayor calls medieval
critical infrastructure continues to get
hit with a special focus on military
airfields like here in lutsk north east
of kiev and ivanov frankevsk in the west
as evacuation routes continue out of
some embattled places a tide of humanity
is shifting across this country and not
all of it heading for the border the
united nations estimates a million
people have become displaced internally
seeking shelter where they can find it
like zhenya the 24 year old mother of
three stoking the wood fire in an
abandoned farmhouse 600 kilometers from
her home outside kiev
they even brought the dog a labrador pup
called girder
but they didn't bring dad
he stayed behind to join the territorial
defense
the children know that their dad is
defending the city they understand that
i believe in one year it will be over
and will be able to go back
zhenya and her children are being
relocated now to a better home in the
village this tiny rural outpost in
western ukraine like so many others
throwing their arms wide open to fellow
ukrainians fleeing the war
the un also estimates that 12 million
people inside ukraine will need
humanitarian help
and few besides zhenya are guessing how
long it might be before they're able to
go home joe nahul al jazeera love